welcome to hannity we begin tonight fox
news alert huge news
as we predicted 45 republican senators
including mitch mcconnell
yes they did vote in favor of a motion
declaring the proceeding again
proceedings against former president
donald j trump
are unconstitutional now this latest
democratic impeachment shift show
is now officially dead in the water it's
over
the senate trial will be conducted as
planned but
democrats do not have anywhere close to
what would be the two-thirds
supermajority
that would be needed to convict barring
of course any completely unlikely
last-minute reversal from people that
are weak and would go against their own
constitutional beliefs
donald trump will be acquitted and what
we will witness is yet another colossal
waste of time
with a predetermined outcome a show
trial a faux trial
predicated on irrational psychotic rage
of the radical left and the cowardly
democrats
in complete fear and panic to stand up
to their base
they must appease this lunatic fringe
that controls the entire democratic
party and establishment
the u.s senate cannot validate
this insane as jonathan turley has been
telling us snap impeachment
you know the one with zero evidence zero
investigation
zero defense no deliberation and keep in
mind
we now have reports all over the place
from even the washington post and fake
news cnn
court documents real court documents
showing that
investigators believe a lot of planning
was made in advance of
what happened at the capitol on january
the 6th
in other words well the president didn't
cite an insurrection
in fact we're learning many of those
that breached the capitol
ignored the president's own words some
of you will peacefully and patriotically
be marching to the capitol so your
voices will be heard
make no mistake this trial will now
accomplish nothing
it's political theater frankly at its
worst it's washington at its worst
it's a massive government waste of time
and resources
and by the way money in the middle of a
pandemic
needed monies you have a divisive
self-serving political charade
and one last smear one one for the
gipper
of former president trump and the 75
million americans
who voted for him and of course another
way for democrats to raise money
which they're trying to do to appease
their radical socialist-based
now even joe biden admitted that there
are not enough votes to convict
yet mr unity still believes the
show trial impeachment must go on chief
justice roberts to his credit
he's refusing to participate what are
clearly
unconstitutional proceedings that speaks
volumes about the legitimacy of the sham
impeachment
roberts not exactly a trump fan that i
can see
now democratic senator patrick leahy
well he's going to fill the void left by
the chief justice
leahey vowed to be an impartial impaired
judge
despite previously calling for trump to
be convicted in the case
this is a pathetic kangaroo court it's
unconstitutional for the senate
to try a private citizen and remove him
from an office they no longer hold
the senate has no jurisdiction never
mind the man presiding over the senate
trial
is nothing but a partisan democrat who
already vowed conviction for the
president
and by the way democrats are attempting
to convict a
former president on a bogus incitement
charge
that they themselves if they ever well
examine their own words
are guilty of earlier today in a
powerful speech senator rand paul
kentucky
he called out this rampant hypocrisy the
hypocrisy we've been calling out
regularly on this program
if we are about to try to impeach a
president
where is the chief justice if the
accused is no longer president
where is the constitutional power to
impeach him
private citizens don't get impeached
impeachment is for removal from office
hyper-partisan democrats are about to
drag our great country
down into the gutter of rancor and
vitriol
the likes of which has never been seen
in our nation's history
it's almost as if they have no ability
to exist except
in opposition to donald trump without
him as their boogeyman they might have
to legislate
and to actually convince americans that
their policy prescriptions
are the right ones